que vous vous puissiez expliquer à ceux
qui nous regardent comment johann a pu
se retrouver dans une situation pareille
et est-ce que c'est un phénomène connu
dans l'univers du football professionnel
malheureusement oui vol escroquerie abus
de confiance extorsion en bande
organisée association de
malfaiteurs aussi dingue que cela puisse
paraître beaucoup de grands sportifs
sont l'objet d'arnaque ou de tentative
d'arnaque c'est fréquent le schéma il
est toujours le même on en a parlé tout
à l'heure des jeunes qui soudainement ne
sont pas préparés à gérer l'argent les
vautours arrivent et l'étape clé c'est
que c'est vutour je vais pas parler de
l'affaire de Lan elle est en instruction
moi journaliste je vais rester prudent
mais le phénomène on le connaît l'étape
clé c'est ce moment où les escrocs
réussissent à gagner la confiance de
l'escroquer comment pourquoi je sais pas
si si tu peux nous le raconter ce
moment-là toi c'est ça qui est fou mais
c'est tout aussi fréquent le reste on
con ça enfin il y a d'autres stars qui
sont fait escroquer Philippe des
footballeurs célèbres encore plus que
que Johann Mollo comme Alain Gires qui a
été l'un des premiers dans les années 80
un ami à lui le convain d'investir dans
une société d'articles de sport plus ou
moins par correspondance comme par
hasard la société elle fait elle fait
elle dépose le bilan et Alain Gires à
l'époque perd pratiquement toute sa
fortune c'est-à-dire l'équivalent de 2
million d'euros c'était en franc à
l'époque depuis des joueurs bah
internationaux champions du monde que
tout le monde connaît ont eu des
affaires Ngolo Kanté Ngolo Kanté en
justice a vu son affaire classé pas de
suite car il n'est pas parvenu à trouver
le vrai escroc il s'est attaqué à celui
qu'il pensait l'avoir arnaqué mais
c'était pas le bon Hussein Bolt Hussein
Bolt star planétaire champion olympique
il place dans son pays dans le fond le
plus sérieux le plus connu une épargne à
hauteur de 12 millions d'euros quelques
années après il va chercher son argent
en penser qu'il en pensant qu'il avait
fructifié il lui reste 12000 € non mais
c'est c'est incroyable ça parce que
parce que parce qu'il y a autant autant
de cas que d'arnaques différentes là
husin Bolt c'était dans cet
établissement financier qui avait pignon
sur rue une employée qui avait volé
l'argent des 40 plus grandes fortunes
donc on peut être
directement
indirectement il faut vraiment se méfier
on accuse souvent les sportifs les
footballeurs de rester un peu dans leur
Bull de faire attention ben ouais ils
font attention et vous savez quoi
dernier mot ils font attention à leur
famille aussi
is bien sûr parce que c'est votre
famille qui en souffre aussi aujourd'hui
de votre situation non parce que il peut
y avoir des ah oui des proches mais oui
on a eu des exemples l'affaire Pogba en
a parlé dans tespmp il y a pas longtemps
est en instruction je vais pas aller
plus loin mais mais là c'est en famille
ou entre amis d'enfance c'est horrible
ça Johan vous vous avez senti vous
autour de vous V amis d'enfance votre
famille là vous avez derre d'être très
proche de de vos parents mais des
changements de comportement quand vous
avez réussi vous avez gagné ce que vous
avez gagné euh avant ou après non avant
avant avant quand j'étais bien ben en
fait moi j'ai toujours g regardé le le
même mon papa ma maman les gens qui qui
m'ont fait du bien étant petit j'ai été
reconnaissant en vers eux toute ma vie
en fait d'cord et aujourd'hui est-ce qu'
est-ce qu'il vous aide est-ce qu'il a
certains vous ont tourné le dos euh
beaucoup quand même ah ouacoup B c'est
sûr que quand on passe de de la lumière
à l'obscurité c'est sûr que c'est on va
se dire quelque part on a plus rien
attirer de la personne mais moi comme
j'ai fait les choses avec mon cœur je
leur en veux pas parce que quand j'ai
fait les choses je voulais le faire donc
j'ai aucun problème avec ça en fait et
votre procès commence commence lundi
ouais c'estchat il y a un chiffre qui
est alarmant c'est l'UNFP qui le donne
l'UNFP c'est le syndicat des joueurs pro
50 % des joueurs donc un joueur pro sur
deux en France se retrouve ruiné après 5
ans après la fin de sa carrière donc
c'est un joueur sur deux c'est énorme ma
question maintenant à Johann c'est quand
on a gagné des des centaines de milliers
d'euros par mois à l'époque et
qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve je pas
être indiscret mais avec des sommes avec
un peu moins de zéro euh comment on fait
en fait comment fait pour réduire son
train de vie parce que là il y a des
crédits à la conso il y a 5 millions de
dettes mais je vais pas te mentir chaque
mois je paye le je pay encore le je paye
encore le crédit maison que je acheté à
ma sœur donc en gros ce que je veux te
dire c'est que même dans ce moment-là je
fais tout pour pour alléger ma tu vois
mais euh en fait vu que j'ai jamais eu
de dépenses extravagante moi mon kiif
c'était j'allais m'acheter un petit Jean
tu vois je me faisais une petite sortie
j'allais en boîte je claqué 5 600 € j'ai
pas eu ce truc de me dire tout claqué
voilà une fois une fois je me rappelle
une fois je suis à la philipelin j'ai
claqué 30000 € mon père il m'a pas parlé
pendant 3 semaines dis mais tu as pété
les plans qu'est-ce que tu fais
qu'est-ce que tu fais pas et si j'ai
bien compris tes agents euh
t'encourageit en plus à ne pas trop
dépenser mais c'est ça en te disant fait
tout carrière ma carrière c'était j'ai
envie de me faire péter une Lambo non tu
peux pas parce qu'en gros tu vas faire
n'importe quoi faut épargner regarde
incroable est-ce que vous savezan ce
qu'ils ont fait de l'argent eux ouis
mais en fait si si vous regardez est-
que le train de vie est
explosé il y en a un je pense qu'à part
parler de de voiture de montre de choses
matérielles je pense qu'il a aucun
argument dans la vie c'est une pauvre
personne et je pense ça me fait de la
peine pour lui non mais il a de l'argent
est-ce que ça se voit est-ce que ah oui
pu il pue l'argent il l'argent par
contre l'autre non l'autre il a l'air de
il a l'air de d'être miné par la vie
parce qu'en fait je il a la culpabilité
non je pense pas et c'est c'est ce que
je me suis posé pendant peut-être 15 ans
de ma vie chaque soir parce que vous
savez que quand on vit ce genre de
traumatisme là aujourd'hui je voilà mais
vous savez comencer on est tous des
êtres humains on a tous une part ou on a
mal et je me suis posé cette question 15
ans est-ce que une seule fois elle a
senti un remord de se dire ce que je lui
ai fait est-ce que c'est pas bien mais
moi j'en arrivé à la conclusion que non
parce que je pense que quand on détruit
les gens comme ça ça quand on détruit
des familles et le pire c'est pas ça
c'est parce que quand pendant autant de
temps tu es assis avec la personne P
pendant 13 ans il mange à ta table il
vient au mariage tu tu tu vis tout avec
lui et que pendant 13 ans la personne
est capable de te mentir c'est mais
c'est pire que ça parce que c'est pire
que ça c'est pas mensonges se servent de
voust ouais ouais c'est fort mais après
le pire c'est pas ça c'est que moi
j'étais seul moi j'étais seul dans dans
tout ça parce que moi j'étais beaucoup à
l'étranger donc quand j'avais pas les
réponse à mes questions c'était des
questions réponses interminables ouais
quand l'argent rentre mardi j'attends
des mardi mardi prochain mardi prochain
mardi prochain et à partir de là tu
dépend tu commences à développer une
certaine forme d'anxiété parce que tu
dis là je pense qu'ils sont ils
commencent à me manipuler parce que tu
commences un peu à moi quand on commence
à me dire Johan tu prends 100 200 300000
€ moi automatiquement mes dépenses elles
augmentent je me dis attends je dis
attends c'est normal je vais me faire un
kiff je vois je vois je vois une montre
à 10000 ou des trucs comme ça je me dis
pourquoi pas je prends 300000 € c'est
quoi 300 c'est quoi 10000 € sur 300 mais
le problème c'est que quand tu mets ta
carte elle passe pas une fois deux fois
trois fois quatre fois tu dis il y a un
problème là qu'est-ce qui se passe et
après on te parle que je sais pas quoi
mais les banques excusez-moi mais vous
avez jamais appelé votre banqu en fait
avec quatre banques en fait quand j'ai
quand j'ai découvert ça avec quatre
banque en fait j'ai quatre comptes dans
quatre banques différentes où j'ai dû
envoyer ma tête écrire un texte comme
quoi je voulais avoir accès à mes
informations parce que quand j'appelle
la banque et je leur demande mes
informations ils me disent vous êtes pas
Yan molo non c'est énorme ça non mais
mais attends Philippe non mais c'est un
truc de fou si j'ai bien compris ton
histoire tu as ou tu aurais été
excuse-moi moi je reste prudent victime
carrément de mise en scène c'est ça
c'est-à-dire de faux rendez-vous
orchestrés avec des complices des
complice faux représentants des faux
établissements financiers qui gèent les
investissements les placements les
achats et CER et B quand tu viens ouvrir
un compte demand une carte une pièce
d'ident lui il fait confiance il par ont
même fait signer des des documents en
lang étrangère je crois en russe en
russe en fait j'ai signé un seul
document mais dans ma dans ma chance
c'est qu'en fait la plupart des
documents c'est pas moi qui les parf et
c'est pas moi qui les signe c'est ça ma
chance parce que si ça aurait été moi
qui aura par làez ouais ce document si
c'est moi là si vous regardez bien je
crois il se vire 250000 € vous voyez en
haut à droite euh en bas regardez là où
c'est flouté en fait c'est son nom mais
la somme c'est qu'en fait il en fait il
m'a fait signé une procuration en fait
en l'esace de de 5 minutes il a viré
500000 € il a envoyé 250000 sur un
compte et il a pris 250000 en cash parce
qu'en fait il a commissionné des gens en
russe en Russie qui eux aussi faisaient
partie de ça heureusement que tu n'as
pas trop ou voir pas du tout àoser tes
signatures là où on te l'a demandé parce
que certaines des victimes que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure ont eu la naïveté
voilà c'est de la naïvé tout simplement
de signer des cautions de société et
cetera et ça mais vous pouvez plus rien
faire est-ce que tu dis j'étais
négligent négligent mais mais je veux te
dire c'est même c'est même plus c'est
même plus de la négligence parce que
j'ai envie de te dire quand il se passe
ça tu te passes tu te poses toutes les
questions tu refais le monde parce que
tu te dis quel épisode j'ai manqué dans
tout ça c'est ça que tu te poses comme
question ouis vous en voulez vous vous
en voulez aujourd'hui beaucoup c'est
normal vous savez quand vousz quand vous
vivez dans un HLM c'est c'est normal
parce que moi le truc c'est c'est pas
moi en fait ça me fait rien moi c'est le
fait de que ma mère elle a 71 ans Lu
faire monter 5 étages c'est ça moi qui
me fait mal c'est ce genre de détails
moi je m'en fous de alors qu'elle aurait
dû vivre dans une maison ça exactement
moi jeis pas vous savez si moi je demain
je dois m'éteindre dans un studio il il
y a pas de problème moi la seule chose
que je veux que le restant le reste des
années que que mes parents doivent vivre
ou les gens que j'aimes doivent vivre
j'aimerais qu'il les vivent bien et vous
pensez que vous allez récupérer vous
pensez que vous allez récupérer un peu
d'argent là l'ici ce procè je vous mens
pas je viens de découvrir que quand on
poursuit des gens je pense que les
avocat chaque fois qu'on fait un truc
c'est 5000 € par C 5000 € peut-être que
sur la somme qui récupéreront vous
voyezon avec la Somme oui mais je me dis
quelque part dans tout ça je je veux
avoir confiance en notre pays et en la
justice même si voilà vous savez quoi
reviendrait on vous souhaite voilà de
bien commencer ce procès d'obtenir ce à
quoi vous avez droit vous reviendrez de
nous en parler merci beaucoup en tout
cas d'ê venu
témoigner merci les amis merci le pu
tout de suite